[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video I'm
going to be talking about the best thing
about Fukui also known as fooly cooly or
just FLCL in my opinion fooly cooly
first aired way back in the year 2000
and it only has six episodes but the
badass music the unique art style and
the wonderfully insane story line turns
fully cooley into a real cult classic
among anime fan konoba resogun or sonic
a mystery and just last year we learned
that tsunami is going to be co-producing
along with production i.g twelve new
episodes all fully [ __ ] a sequel to
fully [ __ ] this sequel is going to be
broken up into two seasons season 2 and
season 3 and each season will have 6
episodes just like the original anime
the sequel is slated to air from late
2017 to early 2018 fooly cooly creators
Kazuya tsurumaki will be back working on
the project and we know that at least
some of the original voice actors will
be back as well including Haruka's voice
actress Maya meet synteny the rock band
the pillows which made the original OST
is expected to return as well right here
at anime up or we're going to keep you
posted on all the latest news and
updates about the fooly cooly sequel so
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so you can be the first to know now when
I first watch this anime quite a few
years ago I had to admit that I did not
understand that all at first glance but
after re-watching it recently it really
spoke to me I rediscovered the greatness
of this anime and I was inspired to make
this video about the best thing about
fooly cooly in my opinion why this anime
is still such a cult classic seventeen
years after it first there other than
hilarious seems like this one in which
if you slow it down you can clearly see
our main character now done randomly
pulling off mommy meets panties as she
is
getting up and no one even acknowledges
in Indiana makes what makes fooly cooly
so amazing is the social commentary that
it has about the adult world the
brilliance of fooly cooly is that it
demonstrates that the so-called adult
world makes no sense it is crazy and all
over the place and it is full of
nonsensical cultural and social norms
and expectations the show follows teams
and primarily our protagonist nota as he
tries to understand and come to terms
with the nonsensical nature of the adult
world and its pressures and expectation
I'm sure that at some point all of us
have been told to grow up and to act
mature and children are all expected to
eventually come to meet our definition
of what an adult is if someone does not
meet society's definition of an adult
they're considered crazy they are an
outcast
however fully coolly asks an important
question who is the truly crazy one is
it really children who still have an
open mind who still know how to be
creative and think outside the box who
are not backed into a corner by society
social pressures or is it adults who
often lead completely meaningless lives
just because they believe that that is
what others expect of them that that is
what society expects them to do I want
to start off by talking about the
medical Mechanica factory which is a
giant factory shaped like an iron for
ironing clothes and which is introduced
right at the beginning of the first
episode we are told that all the adults
were happy when the factory came to town
but our protagonist Natha who is a sixth
grader sees the factory as a bad omen
and he doesn't understand it we are also
introduced to Haruka Haru Hara who is an
alien investigator working for the
Galactic Space Police Brotherhood and
she becomes a housekeeper of sorts in
mouth as household while she's
investigating medical Mechanica
on earth in Episode two Haruko actually
crashes her Vespa in
the medical Mechanica building
pretending that it was an accident and
she notes that there are no entrances or
exits on this factory and this is an
important fact that I'm going to come
back to later as it turns out our
protagonist Malta actually has a portal
in his head that allows objects and even
creatures from other parts of the
universe to teleport to earth something
from medical Mechanica seems to trigger
the portal in Otto's head to open and
this brings forth creatures and objects
including the robot Conti to earn I will
return to talking about the portal
inside Malthus head in a little bit but
for now it is important to note that the
activities of this portal are clearly
affected by activities from medical
Mechanica
along with how to close interference
into now the life in episode 6 medical
Mechanica release a smoke that surrounds
the entire city and to this now to says
when you're in a town covered with smoke
you forget that there's a world outside
nothing happens here we get used to a
world where everything is ordinary
eventually we learned that medical
Mechanica has actually been flattening
planets throughout the galaxy flattening
them with their iron shaped factories
and of course to flatten means to make
boring to make everything the same to
conform medical Mechanica
is the symbol of the conformism of the
adult world it flattens everything and
makes it the same it covers everything
in the smoke of everyday life and keeps
us from seeing the extraordinary things
in life and there are no entrances or
exits because the adult world with its
rules and social pressures and
expectation is so immersive that we
forget that there is an outside world at
all the iron is an apple for the adult
world for the need to conform and never
have a wrinkle out of place we cannot
leave the factory the machine because we
forget that we entered it in the first
place we forgot that there was ever an
alternative
this adult world it is important to know
that well the anime Haruko is looking
for a toast the most powerful space
pirate who has been imprisoned by
medical Mechanica and the interesting
part is that both Haruko and atoms use
guitars to fight against medical
Mechanica now personally i think that
these guitars are a reference to punk
music and punk subculture and the punk
subculture is all about being
anti-establishment and being anti
conformist at one point how to cope
famously states that eating bad rum and
can be fun too and I think that this
quote really speaks to the
anti-establishment and anti conformance
attitude of the anime breaking adult
rules breaking the rules of the adult
world can be fun too and now back to the
portal in mouse's head this power is
known as an O and it is the ability to
summon objects through light-years of
space to instantly teleport to earth and
so throughout the anime we see objects
and creatures literally growing out of
Nagas head and appearing on earth which
seems bizarre and strange when you're
watching it for the first time but I
think that in fully cooley this bizarre
occurrence symbolizes how the creative
and new ideas of the youth are seen as
strange and bizarre by the adult world
the name itself and all could be saying
that the only way to escape the
conformity of the adult world is to say
no to all its rules and restriction so
in fooly cooly the key to escaping the
insanity of the adult world comes quite
literally out of the minds of the youth
along with social norms
bully coolly also makes references to
cultural norms and in episode 1 we
learned that Malta has a brother named
cocoon who actually left Japan to play
baseball in America in doing so he
abandoned his family and mummy knee a
girl who loves him in Japan it is
implied that the brother does not stay
in touch with the family very often but
in the very
this episode we get a glimpse of a
letter that he sends back home to Japan
the letter contains a picture of
Malcolm's brother and his girlfriend and
our note written by the brother said I
got me a blonde gal now we know
logically that a person's hair color
should make no difference but because
blonde girls are so rare in Japan
malthus brother feels like bragging he
feels special about the fact that he
found a blonde girlfriend in America in
many ways this scene symbolizes the fact
that in Japan and many other non-western
countries there are a lot of people who
strive to be more Western not because it
makes any logical sense necessarily but
just because it is considered cool to be
Western as someone from Eastern Europe
and specifically Serbia I can speak to
this on a personal level whenever I go
to visit my family back in Serbia I
noticed that a lot of people there have
a completely unrealistic and idealized
view of what the West is really like and
they strive to be more Western and copy
the cultural and social norms of the
West that they see on TV in the media
and so on
and speaking of mommy me she is a girl
who is in love with malthus brother but
was abandoned by him when he moved to
America so she spent her time hanging
out with Nauta and flirting with him and
also calling him by his brother's name
Taku now mommy is a really interesting
character in my opinion because she is
portrayed as an outcast throughout the
anime because she doesn't fit society's
expectations
mommy meet is bullied rejected by
maltose family for being a bad influence
and also mocked by mouses friends it is
hinted that several years earlier she
was bullied so badly at school that she
actually burned down the school as a way
of acting out the word never knows best
are shown to be written on mommy meat
cigarette and this is another statement
about the adult world and adult
expectations noting mommy knee does will
ever be good enough until she meets the
standards that society has for being
normal in Episode three we see
had ears growing out of mouth of head
and near the end of this episode after a
sharp sound from the medical Mechanica
factory his ears disappear but spikes
grow out of the head of arey
who is his classmate and the daughter of
the mayor of their town this happens as
they are arguing about the school play
which makes for an interesting
juxtaposition of school life and the
adult world childhood and adulthood the
spikes on Aries head then turned into
some sort of steampunk spider that
attacks Conti the robot and chases after
him and Haruko as this is happening the
teacher screams after them not to run in
the hallway which again speaks to the
absurdity of the rules of the adult
world sometimes adults are so blinded by
their rules and norms that they can't
see what's really important in life in
that same episode we see everyone at
Mouse's house eating manhattan-style
curry that Haruko had made even though
the father and grandfather are visibly
uncomfortable eating is because it is
too spicy they do not complain and they
even praise the food alta is the only
one to complain that it is too spicy to
which era replies that he is a child and
that the curry is an adult taste this
again shows that the rules of the adult
world are absurd they eat something that
they are clearly uncomfortable eating
just because it is expected of them as
adults they're expected to appreciate
this type of taste even can't eat the
robot is shown eating curry in this seat
and since we know that robots don't need
to eat human food this speaks to the
pervasiveness of the rules and norms of
the adult world they are everywhere they
are inescapable and they rub off on
everyone there is also a reference to
the little prince at the end of this
scene the little prince curry is the
name of the brand of curry that area
which is actually mild and not spicy
because it is for kids and not adults
the reference here to the little prince
is no coincidence
the teapot is a famous children's book
by French author on 12 assaulted
superheat this book is all about the
beauty of childhood and the strangeness
of the adult world a part of the book
features a child known as the little
prince traveling through space and
visiting various asteroids
each of the asteroids has one irrational
and narrow-minded adult blooming there
and every one of them represents some
sort of nonsensical element of the adult
world we meet a man who calls himself a
king but has no subject a man who drinks
to forget the shame of being a drunk and
a man who doesn't appreciate the beauty
of the stars because he is too busy
counting them and he thinks that if he
counts the stars and documents them he
will own them and become rich the
ultimate message of the little prince is
very similar to the message of fooly
cooly many aspects of the adult world
make no sense adults are often too
narrow-minded to appreciate the most
beautiful and the simplest things in the
world and it is often children who are
the most innocent and not yet corrupted
by the adult world who can see the truth
about life and the true meaning of life
much easier than adults can I really
loved this exchange in Episode four
between Alta and Haruko Nauta asks how
to cope who are you really and how to
core applies I'm an illusion of kakuzu
the memories of an adolescent heart here
how to code is calling maltitol Kuhn by
his brother's name
just like mummy me does not attend
replies what's that problem some anime I
really love this exchange because it
implies that Haruko is the embodiment of
mouth as youthful rebellion against the
adult world how cool doesn't care about
the rules how to code doesn't conform
and she can see the adult world and
medical Mechanica
for what it really is she can see
outside the box in episode 5 now tom
breaks the fourth wall to ask do you
guys find this hard to understand -
which Haruka replies that
playing the guitar will make him look
mature and will make him popular with
the ladies again the point here is that
the rules of the adult world are
nonsensical they are difficult to
understand but everyone still adopts
them because they believe that they have
no other choice they believe that it's
the only way that they will impress
others and be popular with the ladies in
this episode we also see mommy me say to
Nauta you do foody Coody and poopy poopy
and googly googly when did you become
all grown up like this but what are
these words what do they mean and why
does mommy me use them at this point to
describe Nauta acting like a grown-up
well these words mean nothing of course
they make no sense and that is exactly
the point the adult world makes no sense
and Malta by acting like an adult is
acting in a nonsensical way in episode 6
the final episode we see a lot of
breaking of the fourth wall including
the question what does fully coolly even
mean and now that is being asked what it
means because he as the main character
should know now top finally answers that
it doesn't matter what full equally
means and that is exactly it it isn't
supposed to mean anything it isn't
supposed to make sense because it
symbolizes the often nonsensical nature
of the adult world so many things in
this anime are hectic they're all over
the place and they don't make sense
because this anime is a representation
of the adult world with all of its
craziness and contradiction in the end
despite NASA trying to act like an adult
at certain points in the anime both how
to cope and Eddie tell them that he is
after all still a child and it is a good
thing that he is I actually didn't know
about this little hidden easter egg in
the show until I was finishing the
research for this video and I saw an
older video by Aki theorists on fully
cool
check this out number 9 content logo
that flashes in episode 1 was actually a
combination of two Kanji symbols the
symbols placed side-by-side actually
translate to adult this symbol then
appears again in Episode four before now
four swings the best however by the end
of the anime the symbol that pops up is
an adult but rather to Kanji symbols
that sell child so we can take this to
mean the now that goes from trying to
act like an adult to realizing in the
end that being a child is better that
the adult world makes no sense and that
he shouldn't try to become one of them
that he shouldn't try to be trapped in
the box of the adult world
shout out to occupy us for making her
video on Easter eggs and fooly cooly and
I will leave the link to that video in
the description so why does all of this
matter why is fully Cooley such an
important anime it's because we right
now are living in this adult world we
live in a world where things like money
is all that matters where the truth can
be bought with that same money through
media propaganda and where those who are
already powerful get to decide what the
rest of us should and should not do as
anime fans how many times have we been
told to grow up to act our age to do
what everyone else wants us to do
instead of doing what makes us happy
when you are told to act your age what
you are really being told is to conform
to the rules and expectations of society
you are being told to stop being
creative and stop thinking outside the
box I recently saw a handout that is
being given to future high school
teachers by their university professors
and this handout featured an image that
warned students that they could lose a
potential job opportunity if they write
something inappropriate on social media
or if they make an embarrassing you
to video now of course we know that
sometimes people post ridiculous things
on social media and everyone should know
that when you post something publicly
it's going to stay public however what
this handout what this image is really
telling us is to conform to conform to
the rules and expectations of society to
conform to the rules and expectations of
some employer before we even get the job
it's telling us to censor ourselves to
stop being creative because we might
lose a potential job somewhere in the
future I spent many years of my life in
academia getting my PhD in an atmosphere
where creativity was discouraged we have
to censor ourselves and everything has
to be politically correct and it is this
same institution the university the high
school and so on that is raising future
generations of children and teaching
them to conform to do only what others
want them to do but I'm here to tell you
don't listen to these people don't be a
robot don't be a zombie be yourself be
creative and think outside the box I'm a
grown man with a PhD making videos about
Japanese cartoons and I love it is that
embarrassing does it mean that one day
someone won't give me a job because of
this embarrassing YouTube video guess
what I don't care I don't need your job
I only get one life and I want to do
what makes me happy I want to think
outside the box I don't want to grow up
in the way that you imagine growing up
should be I want to be me I don't want
to work at medical Mechanica where there
are no entrances and no exits I want to
be myself I want to have fun and eating
bad ramen can be fun too and what did
you guys think did you enjoy this show
do you agree with the points that I made
here and are you looking forward to the
sequel let me know down in the comments
I'd love to hear from you and that is it
for this video as always thank you so
much for watching and if you're new to
the channel be sure to subscribe and hit
that notification bell and until next
time see ya
[Music]
space cowboy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]